le canada est le plus grand exportateur
de graines de moutarde au monde mais
d'une année à l'autre les rendements ne
s'améliore pas beaucoup dans l'ouest
canadien entend donc de développer une
moutarde à haut rendement
[Musique]
le sud-ouest la saskatchewan ses
paysages bucoliques ces contrées
vallonné qui s'étendent à l'infini sous
un ciel immense
[Musique]
mourir enjoy et ses parents cultive ici
des céréales et des légumineuses sur 500
hectares
depuis 2018 il incorpore une nouvelle
culture à leur rotation la moutarde
[Musique]
on
l'appelle souvent le canola du pauvre
elle coûte une fraction du prix à
produire et nécessite moins d'1 30 le
canola sa culture nous intéresse parce
qu'ici dans le sud ouest on manque
souvent dos et elle résiste mieux à la
sécheresse
après trois bonnes années à cultiver de
la moutarde conventionnelle noyade
décide en 2021 de tenter sa chance avec
une toute nouvelle variété une moutarde
brune hybride
les semences lui coûte le double du prix
mais le potentiel de rendement est
prometteur
[Musique]
on entendait dire que la moutarde
hybride avait au rendement supérieur à
la moutarde conventionnelle de l'ordre
de 19% alors on s'est dit essayons là
depuis deux ans on récolte une moyenne
de 25 boisseau de la cre mais on espère
atteindre 30 boisseau et même plus cette
année sur 65 hectares maureillas m cette
nouvelle variété juste à côté d'un champ
de moutarde brune conventionnel elle
pourra ainsi mieux comparer la
croissance et le rendement des deux
cultures
espérons que les plans seront aussi
grand que moi est en flammes
les étés chauds et les sols sableux de
la saskatchewan se prête bien à la
culture de la moutarde
c'est d'ailleurs ici que l'on cultive la
moitié des graines utilisées dans la
production des moutardes condimentaires
à travers le monde
trois variétés sont cultivées la jaune
la brune et l'oriental
mais cette production est minuscule
comparé aux exportations canadiennes de
grandes cultures comme le blé et le
canola
il y a donc peu d'investissements dans
la recherche agronomique visant à créer
des variétés de moutarde plus
performantes
week mezzo et le directeur exécutif de
sa scm au stade un organisme qui vise à
promouvoir la production et la
transformation de moutarde dans les
prairies mais
les romands moutarde plafonne depuis une
vingtaine d'années il était temps de les
améliorer et de régler certains
problèmes agronomique ces dernières
années le développement de nouvelles
variétés a vraiment fait un bon
et ça c'est surtout grâce à pif unchain
en 2009 elles deviennent la première
sélection officielle de moutarde un
poste créé par agriculture et
agroalimentaire canada
l'objectif est d'augmenter le rendement
tout en améliorant la qualité de la
graine et sa résistance aux maladies
une pauvre désolé s'estompe
pour ce faire elle se tourne vers une
approche utilisée depuis longtemps dans
l'amélioration des grandes cultures
l'hybridation
l'hybridation a permis d'accroître les
rendements de canola de blé et de riz
notamment c'est vraiment efficace
l'hybridation consiste à combiner deux
lignes pures d'une même espèce de plante
pour obtenir des traits particuliers be
fine cheng cherche surtout de bons
indicateurs de rendement
la roumanie poche on examine la densité
et le nombre de gosses ainsi que la
quantité de branches plus légaux sont
nombreuses plus le rendement sera élevé
en 2018 la première variété de moutarde
brune hybride là et si brawn et in est
lancé c'est tout chercheur du week end
contre vichy mejia que l'on confie la
tâche d'optimiser la culture de cette
variété
dans chacune de ses pairs' l on
introduit différentes quantités d'azoté
on varie aussi le nombre de graines de
semences d'une parcelle à l'autre
mbowe dirige le projet
on cherche la bonne quantité d'azoté à
utiliser pour qu'il n'y ait ni
gaspillage ni accumulation surpris dans
le sol on veut que les plans absorbe
tout
avec cet hybride on espère aussi
utiliser moins de semences aux pieds
carrés ce qui réduirait les coûts
oui exactement
en 2019 une dizaine de producteurs de
grains tentent leur chance avec la
moutarde hybride les rendements sont
généralement 20 % plus élevé qu'avec les
variétés conventionnelles
les promoteurs de la récolte espère que
l'arrivée de cet hybride incitera
davantage de fermiers à se lancer dans
la production de moutarde
les écarts se met en mode hard ont
diminué depuis trois ou quatre ans
surtout en fonction du revenu élevé que
rapporte canola mais je pense qu'il y
aura un retour à la culture de la
moutarde
toutefois les conditions climatiques de
la saison agricole 2021 n'aide en rien
l'atteinte de cet objectif
une sécheresse historique frappe la
saskatchewan
les températures frôlent les 40 degrés
pendant des semaines
c'est le sud ouest de la province qui
est le plus touché
à la fin juin la récolte de moutarde de
meaux ryan jones est déjà en fleurs deux
semaines plus tôt que d'habitude
on voit que cette fleur a souffert de la
chaleur en temps normal ces tiges
mesurait 6 pouces de plus et les goûts
serait aussi plus longue
laplante a subi un choc étant de faire
des graines mais les gosses ne se
rempliront sûrement pas
bright a créé pour ses rendements et
surtout elle ne croit pas être en mesure
de comparer les rendements de ces
cultures de moutarde conventionnelle et
de moutarde hybride
[Musique]
j'espérais me faire une bonne idée de la
performance des deux variétés mais dans
une année comme on a connu les plantes
lèvent le drapeau blanc
à saskatoon be fine chaîne y voit le
côté positif de la sécheresse
elle servira peut-être à rendre les
prochaines variétés hybrides plus
résistantes au réchauffement du climat
le stress causé par la chaleur est une
bonne façon de voir les différences
entre les variétés
la chercheuse développe aussi une
nouvelle variété de moutarde orientale
hybride mais pour la mouteyre de jaune
la variété la plus cultivée au pays il
faudra attendre plusieurs années encore
avant d'en arriver à une variété hybride
le système reproductif de la moutarde
jaune est une ex qui rend le processus
d'hybridation plus long c'est pourrait
bien devenir la tâche du prochain
sélectionneur de moutarde nexter moi
c'est auprès des seniors
le canada est probablement le seul pays
producteurs de moutarde hybride
selon lui ces nouvelles variétés
hybrides pourrait permettre au canada de
prendre une avance quasi insurmontable
au rang des pays exportateurs de
moutarde
hybridation permet de sélectionner des
traits spécifiques par exemple si les
transformateurs recherche une certaine
uniformité dans la taille des grains on
peut leur donner ça offre un réel
avantage aux fermiers canadiens
les petits transformateurs de moutarde
canadiens accueillent favorablement
l'arrivée de variétés hybrides
à la moutarderie de julien moret à
montréal on se réjouit de l'arrivée de
ces nouvelles variétés sur le marché
dans la mesure où la qualité y est la
qualité des grains la teneur en huile
c'est très important pour nous donc si
on est capable de conserver le taux de
l'huile dans le grain pour nous c'est
vraiment ce qui nous importe ils
soutiennent que bien des consommateurs
ne savent pas que la grande majorité des
moutardes à l'épicerie sont fabriqués à
partir de graines canadienne sa
stratégie de marketing cible justement
l'achat local la montagne qu'on a porté
ses les graisses au parti du canada
c'est aller ça a pris le bateau
s'appelle en chine ce talent en europe 7
s'est transformé ses revenus ça nous
revient ainsi que nous rachète ça pour
moi sa part fait sens
ce niveau là on veut pas reconnaître
notre produit mais aussi expliquer aux
gens qu'il n'y a pas de raisons
d'acheter un produit qui fait le tour du
monde
[Musique]
fin juillet 2021
angels commencent à récolter sa moutarde
trois semaines plus tôt que d'habitude
la sécheresse a décimé séchant les
rendements sont réduits de moitié à la
fois dans la moutarde hybride et la
variétés conventionnelles
les rendements sont les mêmes partout
c'est une très mauvaise amis pour
comparer les deux variétés
ces pertes seront plus grande danse et
chant hybride puisque la semence lui a
coûté le double du prix elle n'écarte
toutefois pas la possibilité de refaire
l'expérience l'été prochain
on n'a pas pu mesurer qui le vrai
potentiel de la moutarde brune hybride
c'est très décevant mais on va réessayer
l'année prochaine ça peut être
excellente c'est ça la vie de fermier
[Musique]